dis-moi si tu me veux, mon amour ou
quoi que ce soit,
ouais, je
viens d'arrêter la scène vers le
barrage maintenant, je pense que c'est un peu comme sa dernière
nuit où ça deviendra plus clair à mesure que nous descendons un
peu à ma droite, ça pourrait être
plus clair parce qu'alors le soleil sera
directement derrière moi ok ouais mec essaie
ça
pourrait devenir un peu mieux hein
ça aide ouais c'est ouais c'est
bien
trouver descend que nous sommes en bas quand
nous arrivons au barrage ou tu
continues probablement à envoyer légèrement
euh, quel genre de chute encore cinq
minutes, d'
accord,
peut-être que tu pourrais faire comme un tir vertical
vers le bas, ouais, d'accord, ouais,
ça se met en place un peu
mieux en ce moment, ouais,
laisse-moi passer par-dessus le barrage,
juste par-dessus, oui,
ça a l'air beaucoup mieux maintenant et c'est
comme si c'était moins paresseux c'est
sympa
laisse-le comme ça et puis on
recommencera en
étant un plan vertical
ok
on peut faire demi-tour ok
même altitude tu veux le faire c'est
juste ça qu'on va faire  la même chose
mais un conditionnement vertical sur moi,
qu'est-ce que c'est que tu veux encore
shot et puis on
fera quelques détails d'eux
sur le réservoir après
ok tout noir ouais
tu sais l'équipe ils ne sont pas coupés ok
c'est mon truc ouais comme ça vois ce qui
se passe il y
a un peu de merde dessus
et juste comme dans l'eau
merci,
personne ne vient un peu à droite le
long de ce sable, c'est là que le
soleil est du côté de la plage, à gauche à
droite où le soleil brille mieux en
ce moment,
ok,
nous pouvons obtenir un peu plus de ce sable, de
l'eau et tout ça si tu veux  dans une seconde,
je ne suis pas sûr que ça s'arrête, arrête, ok, arrête,
ok, qu'est-ce que tu penses de Dorothy euh
peut-être que cette petite rivière juste euh c'est vrai ouais c'est bien
celle-là donc on
montre que l'eau du
réservoir vient des montagnes  et
va dans la rivière tu veux qu'on
suive ouais ça ressemble à une rivière
tu ne veux pas y aller à la place oui
ouais là-bas nous allons monter à
notre tour à 11 heures ici ok ok eh
bien je  je vais arrêter, tu veux continuer à
enregistrer
et nous mettrons un père de la rivière dans
le réservoir ouais
c'était toujours des amis ouais pas le
mien parfois quand ils mettent à jour l'heure,
ça fait ça trop
étranger
que l'autre petite rivière ressemblait plus à un
rivière, on dirait que je pensais que je ressemble à
un ruisseau, cela ressemble à une rivière,
oh
alors nous aurons les deux, eh
bien, c'est celle-là parce qu'elle montre qu'elle
sort du coin nord-est, je sais,
peut-être que Zuma a mordu à la place, donc nous n'avons pas
le  route qui en sort ouais
et puis nous arrivons quand nous arrivons au
réservoir un peu comme 10,
donc vous ne voulez pas faire de panoramique pendant un moment
parce que nous nous dirigeons
à nouveau vers la route,
je vous le ferai savoir  quand il se détourne,
où sera le reflet dans l'
eau,
laisse-moi mourir de notre nez malheureusement,
oh peut-être que ça ne sera pas mort là où
ça va être comme ouais ouais,
est-ce que ça s'accumule ouais, attends une seconde
parce que nous allons avoir  la chaussée
sinon voilà on y
va maintenant on est détournés de
la route
c'est pas trop ça ouais comme ça
fais juste rouler genre 20 secondes
ok plus plus
jusqu'à 30. étranger étranger étranger